[Music]
[Applause]
today
he's russell wilson jr iii honored with
the walter payton man of the year award
also
he and his wife sierra are on the cover
of gq which hits the newsstands
february 23rd good morning ross how are
you
dan what's up man it's always great
being on the show how you been uh
where's the trophy
oh man the trophy is on its way right
here uh it's going gonna be sitting
somewhere over here somewhere
it's heavy though man it's like it's
like 75 pounds i was lifting anything up
i'd use both hands okay is that your
library
uh yeah this is my office yeah okay what
do you have in it what's coolest thing
you have in your office
i got some good books here um let's see
here have you read those books
uh i haven't read them all no but the
coolest coolest thing i have in my
office man i
i got some cool awards i have this um i
have this uh lombardi
award that i that i won last year um
that was pretty cool i've got some other
cool things in here i'm not gonna say
too much i don't want some might break
you should do a book club like andrew
luck
no book clubs for me uh what'd you think
of the super bowl
man i thought uh first of all the fact
that we were able to get this far
you know with everything going on with
covet and everything else
and for us to be there i was sitting
there watching the game and uh it was
pretty fascinating to just see because
all year we had we had no fans so
it was fascinating to see actually
people there the experience of it all
felt real
um but in terms of the game you know i
think that uh
tom got up early you know and and uh
they threw through a few touchdowns
early on
and and uh you know they you know the
the reality is
they they couldn't block those guys on
the other end you know they just they
struggle with it
you know patrick was running for his
life the whole game felt like but i
didn't understand why kansas city didn't
make adjustments with that offensive
line
right at half time don't you make
adjustments to something like that
yeah you know i think they they need to
adjust a little bit quicker in the game
and then next thing you know they
the you know the bucks were already up
you know pretty good you know in the
first half
you know so i think they were trying to
catch up you know they're always trying
to play catch-up mode in that game
and um you know obviously we've got guys
like tyrique running down the field and
kelsey
but i felt like they moved the ball in
certain moments but then they kind of
got froze you know kind of stuck in the
middle of the field
so that's where they that's where they
had some problems but also and patrick
mahomes has mentioned this
he he's he's trying for the big play and
not taking what the defense gives you
like is do you understand
that and you probably went through this
this year where
you guys were getting the big play but
you weren't getting other things
yeah i think that the biggest thing that
you have to be able to do is you know
they had to slow those guys down up
front
for patrick to be able to you know go
through his reasons it looked like as
soon as he kind of was hitting his back
foot sometimes and then other times
you know they were trying to take shots
down the field you know but i i think
that
um they didn't adjust great but also too
it just it didn't seem like they could
handle the guys up front
does brady do anything that you can't do
does he do anything that i can't do yeah
no he does anything i can't do
um you know i think that he just does he
does everything extremely well he's
got great players i mean i was looking
at the i was looking at the pre-game
warm-ups right i'm looking at
i'm looking watching the pre-game
warwicks and i'm seeing gronkowski
seeing godwin evans antonio brown
uh you know they got they got uh
fournette they got all these players
around them i mean this
i mean watching antonio brown that deep
hinge stop route that he ran
25 yards boom stopped on a dime you'd
have gronkowski
uh just i thought left which called a
great game and got gronkowski open early
in the game and got him open
that was really cool down the red zone
some of the stuff they were doing
um and you know and i think that they
made their plays you know when they
really needed to
um you know in that game does mahomes do
anything you can't do
no man i i think that he he can launch
it a long ways on the field but
i think i can do everything out there
you know he's uh he's a really special
player
though man i i love watching him i love
watching his competitive
drive you know the game was kind of out
of hand there that you know he just kept
going for it which i loved
watching him go for it you know even
though it yeah it didn't turn out the
way he wanted it to he's a
he's been a heck of a player for a long
time how much input
should the quarterback have in
organizational moves
veteran quarterback yeah i think it
depends on who it is you know i think
well how about you how much
do you have any say in what seattle does
offensively with free agents or draft
draft picks uh uh i think that it's uh
you know i think that ultimately for me
personally i you know i think that i
want to be able to
be involved because at the end of the
day it's your legacy it's your team's
legacy
it's you know it's the guys you get to
go into the huddle with and at the end
of the day
those guys you gotta trust you know when
you think about you know one of the
reasons why tom went to
tampa was because he felt like he could
trust those guys and bruce would give
him an opportunity i think
i think for you know every situation you
have to be able to
go into a situation you know you think
about guys like lebron he was able to
you know be around great players he can
trust i think for for me
you know uh anytime you bring free
agents in you know other players you
want the best players guys who
love the game guys you want to be a part
of that and as a player you kind of know
that you get to be around pro bowls you
get to kind of see these guys you get to
be in the huddle with the lineman or or
receivers or
you know um get to be around defensive
guys and so you gotta you kind of build
that over time and get to see who can
really play you know as a player you
really know so
i think that um i think that
relationship's really key and that
dialogue between
you know um you know especially being a
veteran player you know that dialogue is
really important yeah but that's a
long-winded way of not answering my
question
are you involved in personnel decisions
have you been involved in personnel
decisions
not not as much i don't you know i think
that uh you know
do you want to be involved russ yeah i
think it helps i think it helps
to be involved more um but i think
that's that dialogue
should happen more often in my opinion
yeah but look i'm worried about
the these numbers you've been sacked 394
times in your career
so you're you're going to be the most
sacked quarterback in the history of the
game
why well i think that uh
you know sometimes sometimes you hold on
to a little bit you know just because
you're looking for that plague and you
find
you find those guys but also so many so
many times it turns into touchdowns too
but you know to be to be uh you never
want to be sacked that many times you
know 400 times up basically is
is way too many 400 too many um you know
so i think that's a big
it's a big thing that we got to fix
that's got to be fixed you know and has
to be you know at the end of the day
because
and my goal is to play you know 10 to 15
more years and so
you think about that in longevity and
legacy and all that you know i
and you watched the game the other night
you know the difference between that
game was
you know tom was taking shots down the
field and getting the ball
you know to his guys and stuff like that
but you know he wasn't touched really he
got touched i think that sacked one time
in the game
you know um you know early on but you
know throughout that and this doesn't
even count russ how many times you were
hit
i mean that's 394 sacks like
that's a that's a lot and like i
i i think you also get away quite a bit
too you know
i get get i get awake something you do
that's a lot but i i think that you know
we got to get better up front that it's
not just passing i think you know
in terms of everything you do you know
you it controls the game as you watch
the other night i think
you know and um you know obviously guys
like dwayne are such
amazing players and uh you know to have
him come in
was a big thing that that i really
wanted to make sure that happened i
think that we all wanted to make sure
that it happened because
um we knew that what what a great player
dwayne was for example so
you know and so i think that uh you know
throughout the next 10 years it's really
important for me personally and
but also just you know you know
throughout you know my career that
you know we make sure that we do the
everything we can including myself
do everything we can to make sure that
that that doesn't happen
uh we're talking to russell wilson uh
what do you make of uh
cbs jason lochen forest saying that
seattle had
gotten you know calls for uh possible
you know
trade talks with you do you believe that
that uh seattle has
gotten calls yeah i definitely believe
they've gotten calls for sure i didn't
think that
uh you know i think anytime you're um
you know
you know a player that you know tries to
produce every week and
has done it for you know consistently i
think people are going to call for sure
and i think
it's part of the process yeah but you're
a franchise quarterback you're a hall of
fame quarterback
you're not available are you well i'm
not sure if i'm available or not
that's a that's a ceo's question but
also i think more than anything else is
um
you know i think the end of the day you
you want to win you know you play this
game every day to wake up to win you
play this game
you know to to be the best in the world
you know i you know what i hate i hate
sitting there watching other guys play
the game
there's nothing worse by the way you
look miserable at the super bowl
watching yeah there's a picture
there's a picture of sierra and roger
talking i'm sitting there
watching this game like you know wishing
that i was in there not playing
so you know i think that um i think that
you know
ultimately you watch the games and you
know you want to do everything you can
to be there that's why we play this game
you know and so i think that part of
it's
really key and i think that you know the
reality of professional sports is
you know things happen things change you
know you know i'm not sure
you know how how long i'll play in
seattle i think hopefully hopefully it
was going to be you know
be forever you know but things change
obviously along the way and
i think that um you focus on what you
can control every day and try to be the
best version yourself and
ultimately try to win championships and
i think that's um
you know that's why i play this game uh
what's the cover on gq what's it look
like with you and uh your wife
you know just came out this i think it's
just just coming out here this morning
it's coming out soon here but uh
i think it'll look good i think i think
i think you i think you'll like it and
and then i i know you and c have that
good relationship now you guys are
really close so you know i know
you we're not that close any that much
anymore you know once you got married so
i had to be respectful
so i mean backed up yeah yeah i mean i i
backed away
and i was respectful i got you where is
she right now
uh i think she's uh with the kids right
now she's it's early it's early on the
east
on the west coast so it's almost at 7
30. i mean she still looks great
can she do a drive by can you just say
hey
can you come in here and say hello to
dan she's on the other side of the house
she's uh
with a little wind right now wait how
big is the house
don't know it's big enough
it's not like a two-bedroom apartment
that you're in right
no we're not too bad uh what are you
doing in the off-season
man just getting ready i think you know
every every day you try to get ready
to try to get prepared um we have a
pretty cool business too called
limitless minds that's that's growing
like crazy
i think you've talked to trevor uh
trevor before you know it's a business
my brother harry dj
that business is growing we're working
with some of the best companies in the
world we have
the house of lrnc from a business
standpoint too that's really growing
with christine day
she was the former ceo lululemon and me
and sierra
and christine are in the rest of the
team we're running that business and so
it's good because i i don't have to
focus on that every day you know i have
a great
team like people like christine but what
is that business though russ
what is it so we have a good man brand
which is our
clothing line which has been massive and
it's been growing like crazy
and um though goodman brandon it's we
give three percent
back to uh to the wyaneu foundation we
give all those proceeds to the friends
of the children it's amazing program and
it's
uh you know it's it's it's a great
clothing line it's a great shoes
everything you could want to wear i
could run a 40 yard dash in these pants
i'm telling you
and then and then we also have a human
nation that's underneath the house of
lrnc so
imagine how fast do you run the 40-yard
dash well i
yeah i'm a i'm a guy that can run way
faster than you dan that's for sure
i know that but i hope so
but what do you run the 40 now well i'm
probably
i'm probably a low four or five guy
right now i'm more quick than fast
though like i
might the awareness of being like get in
and out of things i think is what's
what's uh what's key especially playing
my position because you you're in small
movements right so you're you're getting
in and out of the pocket you're sliding
to the right slide to left spinning out
so i think that that's what i really
concentrate on but you know right now in
this time of year it's really just
trying to
get ready uh for the season and you know
trying to you know get prepared
and trying to be the best version
yourself how are the kids
man future's growing up fast um you know
he's getting ready for
for all these sports and stuff like that
trying to be safe as possible and
uh he's getting tall and fast and
athletic and then you have
uh sienna who's you know she she knows
everything she's
she's gonna run for president one day
i'm sure and uh and then you have
uh who's you know six months who
you know is getting ready i feel like
he's i think i feel like he's gonna run
before he ever walks so
um he's ready to roll so um the kids are
great
it's the best part of you know after the
season you really get to
you know spend time with your kids and
balance all that out uh
you know quarterbacks hate three and out
but are you three and out that that's it
three kids oh uh i'm pushing c for
for more she she she wants to have more
too but we'll see what happens
uh go for it on fourth down is uh what i
would do if i were you
hey couldn't don't tell her i said that
uh congrats on the walter payton man of
the year award
and uh it's a great honor and uh i don't
know
if it hits you what it meant to you uh
can you describe it yeah man i you know
my whole life you know my dad used to
talk about walter payton and what man he
was a legacy that he had lived and
everything else and i think
you know my dad not being here anymore i
think the reality is is that
you know i to be able to serve and give
back it's the greatest gift
you know in the world you know and i
think that whenever i got in seattle in
2012 i wanted to
be able to serve and give back to the
community and everything else so that's
been something i've been
super passionate about i've met almost a
thousand some kids in sale children's
hospital we've been able to do
do so many cool things with you know uh
you know
pediatric cancer with why not you
foundation and
why not you foundation doing so many
things with you know uh ride united
program this off season and um and
everything else that we've been able to
do along the way especially with kova
that's happened and i'm a voter campaign
and just
it's been a journey you know it's been a
journey especially in 2020 with
all the people that we've lost you know
all the people that you care about and
all the people that
you've gotten to know that experience
different things also all the things
going on
racially in america uh it was important
for me and c to get involved and to
you know even to partner up with you
know wheels up to do meals up with kenny
dictor
it was a blessing to be able to give
back and just really try to make a
difference as much as we could and so um
you know i think that uh i i told i told
c you know the cool part is it's just
the beginning it's just the beginning of
of of really being able to make a
difference and hopefully
hopefully we can continue to do that
along the way i think
your dad went to mclovin's alma mater
your dad went to dartmouth
he did yeah mclovin went to dartmouth
yeah i don't know what that means i mean
your dad was an athlete and
mclevin wasn't did dartmouth recruit you
they did they did actually uh buddy
teavens actually oh yeah
yeah buddy teams i went up to dartmouth
um
it was went up there i don't know i was
probably 10th grade or something like
that
and uh you know my cousin was actually
playing basketball she was playing
basketball at university of penn so i
went up there
everything else and buddy tv's you know
my dad and buddy teams were really close
actually they had a really good
relationship my dad played football and
baseball there and everything
and so uh i went there beautiful camp
and there's so much snow it was probably
it was probably 12 feet of snow when i
went up there i was like i'm not coming
here
but anyways you know my dad uh he he
loved dartmouth big green you know and
so
um that was always fun to be up there
and uncle ben and everything else we had
a good time
hey good to uh good to talk to you have
a good off season and uh we'll stay in
touch and tell your wife i said hello
okay boss i'll oh good to see you man
the glove see you later but
whoa all right